nach rund vierwöchiger cupid 19
zwangspause wird dass harris
sportzentrum in der südstadt wieder in
betrieb genommen
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
nützt die gelegenheit einige
spitzensportler persönlich
kennenzulernen
gemeint ist die bronze medaille die der
heeressportler lukas weißhaidinger bei
den europameisterschaften 2018 in berlin
erinnern konnte
für mehr medaillen braucht es aber mehr
internationale großveranstaltungen und
dann muss die form auch stimmen er wird
dann soweit sein wann es soweit sein
muss wir haben heuer im herbst in europa
meisterschaften
ich denke dass nur der eine oder andere
welt kauft dazu kommt mir uns sicher
nicht den normalen wettkämpfe würde die
menge an wettkämpfen wie man der letzten
jahre gehabt haben was normal ist normal
ist für die spitzensportlerinnen und
spitzensportler zurzeit fast gar nichts
mehr
das größte problem ist die verlorene
trainingszeit und das damit verlorene
form eine form die jetzt so rasch wie
möglich wieder gefunden werden muss in
welcher zeit die verlorenen vier
trainingswochen aufgeholt werden können
ist von der sportart abhängig besonders
zeitintensiv wird die aufholjagd für
marathonläufer weil den jetzt zb vier
wochen nicht im wasser schwimmen
trainieren kann
dann kann ich zwar alternativen
trainingsformen wählen
aber die ersetzen nicht die
sportartspezifischen im wasser im wasser
verliert man natürlich das wassergefühl
die wasser spezifik da wird es sicher
zwei drei wochen brauchen bis wir wieder
das niveau von vor corona erreichen
aber ich bin schon qualifiziert haben in
dem sinne keinen druck mehr und kann
jetzt auch die zeit geben dass ich
gemeinsam mit meinem team das wieder auf
am wenigsten probleme haben österreichs
sprinter dem lauftraining war in den
vergangenen wochen zwar eingeschränkt
aber möglich da ich finde ich sehr gut
ich habe eben mein ziel fragen das habe
ich natürlich nicht verloren hat gut
darauf hingearbeitet hat die quarantäne
ich bestmöglich genutzt
gute form aufgebaut und jetzt gilt es
für mich einfach nur die nächsten
olympischen spiele und andere
großveranstaltungen werden kommen
bis dahin werden die österreichischen
spitzenathleten zu neuen höchstform
aufgelaufen sein so viele haben sich für
diese schwierige zeit eigene dinge
einfallen lassen
aber bahnhof diskus zu werfen das zu
analysieren mit dem trainer gemeinsam
dann über die technischen möglichkeiten
mit mittels video
ich bin überzeugt davon und das sind die
sportlerinnen und sportler auch dass sie
erfolge erzielen werden auf die wir als
österreicher dann unglaublich stolz sein
können und stolz und deshalb in den
letzten wochen und monaten auch immer
wieder gehört sind die österreicher auf
ihre heere sportlerinnen und
heeressportler und gerade in der zeit
wann sich unsere sie sind ja immer auch
soldatinnen soldaten nicht zu schade in
einer schwierigen situation auch in
zusammenhang mit
unterstützungsleistungen regale zum
beispiel ein zu schlichten als das
notwendig war
jetzt drücken wir ein unsere
sportlerinnen und sportlern die mit
optimismus an die sache herangehen
können ganz fest die daumen